hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
at last we have map changes in fortnight
again sadly not to the degree we're used
to but hey I'm miss making these videos
so sit back for 10 minutes slap code a
tomorrow in the fortnight shop and let's
look over all the fortnight Battle
Royale map changes in week 5 of chapter
2 and if you didn't know already if I
hit 1 million subscribers by the end of
the year I shall reveal my ugly face so
please think about subscribing thank you
kindly anyway let's do this the biggest
visual change this week sees the removal
of almost all Halloween scented
decorations which include the storm
Kings home on the central island
bringing back the good old wooden
buildings making up a fishing cabin at
the center of the lake this got me
thinking what if all major events take
place on this central point maybe the
next map update will see a huge
Christmas tree or maybe an egg at Easter
that would simplify a lot of things for
epic and yeah I do expect the season
ending story to take place here so if we
do get a Kraken event I'd put my money
on it being slap-bang in the middle of
the map guys guys
[Music]
so as Halloween locations return to
normal I noticed something happening in
the northwest islands we've all visited
this coral themed area and if you have
music on in game you've heard the
singing but have you noticed that those
singing crustaceans are beginning to
spread from only one or two in week one
to now an army in week five so what
could this be leading to a subtle easter
egg or is this linked to the story
and speaking of story may I make a
little request next week I'd like to
bring back our story theories I have a
few ready to go but I love to be
influenced by what you guys think so
I'll be in the comments for the next few
days if you'd like to contribute to a
story of what the heck is going on in
Chapter 2 season 1 please put it below
and I will try to add it to our
cinematic next week and then we'll bring
back our stream to meetups and we'll
record the cinematics together to sound
good I hope so
so this season we have our first Easter
Egg south of the central island is a
waterfall I'm sure you've jumped off it
many times and maybe you've been trolled
and died landing on someone's builds but
times as a side note you totally should
check out this myth chases episode where
we demonstrate how to survive a dolphin
dive of death well by this waterfall is
a gravesite at first I thought it was a
reference to Niagara Falls
you know the barrel jumpers but a little
bit more research unveiled a guy called
I frost origins who is looking around
the island in week one enjoying new
swimming mechanics but things went awry
they leapt from the top of the waterfall
and mistimed his jump landing straight
down on hard ground instantly double
ripped the drink to mark this momentous
game a moment the epic game dev sets up
this touching memorial right in the
fields and now it's time for bunker
watch each week I sit here and theorize
about this bunker the secrets within its
walls within this vault including the
whereabouts of my dear thick-skinned
penny one day my love we will be
together but it turns out the word of
bunker watch is spreading and from its
humble beginnings we now have a
miniature army waiting for the
monumental day this beast opens but it
isn't today
so we should move on Bunco watch forever
oh man I miss hot watch Oh up in retail
row there is indeed some last remnants
of the Halloween event the store is
still here so take a visit if you missed
it because next week it will be a turkey
day shop or a Christmas takeover maybe
here's another area we should definitely
keep an eye on north of the dam there is
a nursery a tree nursery by the way I
don't mean kindergarten it's not a tumor
it looks like after five weeks the
saplings are growing and replacing the
trees being taken away by these haulage
wagons I'll keep an eye on where they're
going what's their destination for
example the wallpaper we got on day one
of chapter 2 has this truck here about
to cross the bridge but right now in
game it's here yes I know that's not big
news but some of us are here for the
tiny minutiae the little details or
maybe it's just me so did I miss
anything I realize this is a very short
episode so next week yes we are bringing
back the story theories but if I've
missed anything please get in touch with
me on twitter i'm adam grenade over
there and my DMS are always open as
always on screen now is the legend roll
call people who are kind enough to use
my code I'm sorry if you don't see your
name yet I am trying my hardest to get
through all my DMS but I will get there
you have my word thank you once again
okay are we done in dust it so if you
spotted anything give me a shout I'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]